Wolverine and Ghost Rider team up and
then they fight and then they team up
again they're like a high school couple
but this story is amazing now this
initially picks up with kind of a recap
to a degree that we don't need to go
super in depth into suffice it to say in
the Ghost Rider stories Ghost Rider and
Wolverine have kind of been teaming up a
little bit and when I say team up I
simply mean that Wolverine ripped a
demon out of Ghost Rider's head but one
of the things that we're told here is
that the two of them have a lot of
history together and what this does is
this goes way back to the early days of
really Wolverine's career with the X-Men
over at the Xavier Institute and the
arrival of a kid named Bran now here's a
cool thing this kid is like he's like
the kid from The Omen right like
something's just a little off about him
and it's one of these things where no
one knows exactly what it is that's
going on but he is brought to the Xavier
Institute by a woman named Ada now of
course this leads to Wolverine showing
up popping his claws you know being all
intimidating and all that kind of cool
stuff this is back in the day when
Wolverine was like Old Testament so like
death and destruction wrath of God that
kind of thing but of course almost
immediately Xavier appears and then
tells Wolverine to leave and sits down
and starts talking with Ada now what
happens here is as they have this
conversation she's not bringing him here
because she basically is going on the
assumption that he's a mutant she is but
she isn't it's really more that she just
doesn't understand what's happening with
him and she saw on TV how Xavier seemed
to be an expert in mutants and so in
turn she's asking him for some measure
of help now the reason why this is
important is this actually gives us a
time frame and this tells us it happens
around the time of Days of Future Past
which is to say when Xavier was making
the rounds on National Television trying
to publicize the peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants that kind of
thing but what Ada says is that she's a
social worker who's been assigned to
bram's Case and all the other ones had
basically quit and she said that he'd
been in a like a dozen foster homes but
things never seem to work out and she
says that there's just something about
him that scares other people things
happen around him they say pets die
people disappear some say they hear
strange noises a voice that doesn't
sound like his own that doesn't sound
human and of course she asks are you
able to help and one of the cool things
that kind of happens here and this is
actually a great throwback you end up
seeing like Nightcrawler teleport in
grab some ice cream and then like
teleport away kitty Pride shows up and
she's kind of upset about it and then
she leaves this is a throwback to the
Chris Claremont era of the X-Men because
he would do this all the time he would
see like these small little moments that
happen and it would kind of give a
really greater depth to what was going
on just in general with the X-Men at the
time right a lot of background stuff
happening so it was kind of fascinating
but Xavier chooses to read the mind of
this kid and when he does he's met with
a kind of force of energy that is
incredibly overwhelming now there's a
couple things to glean from this right
to the non-x-men experienced person they
would just kind of say okay so like it's
a really powerful being but it's
immensely powerful and the reason for
this is that when it comes to Charles
Xavier even at this point in time his
telepathy was on a whole nother level a
perfect example of this is when he got
into a psychic fight with the Shadow
King and that was the whole basis behind
the formation of the X-Men that he met
the Shadow King in Egypt the two of them
had a kind of psychic battle and then he
realized there were some beings out
there with incredible power that
originate with the kind of mutant Gene
that will just be straight up evil the
Shadow King is kind of like this force
of evil that exists out there right just
like pure darkness that exists in the
Multiverse but realizing that there are
enemies out there like that Xavier
formed the team in the first place the
reality here though is that this kid is
not a mutant and even Xavier says that
right like if this kid were a mutant I
would do what I could to help him but
the reality is that he's not what you're
going to need is somebody who really
delves more into the realm of magic and
mysticism possibly even demonology but
the problem here is Ada gets frustrated
at the idea that there are no answers to
be had and ultimately feels as though
she's kind of being thrown away right
just sort of being dismissed by Xavier
even for Bram himself he's reluctant to
leave he doesn't want to go but he's
sort of drug away anyway you know this
is a very dangerous precedent when it
comes to the X-Men Comics because
anybody who knows anything about mutants
knows that when it comes to this kind of
thing this is when you start getting
into like Clyde wincham territory right
just like the Marquee of death this guy
who was able to wipe out universes with
a wave of his hand different things
along those lines cue every new comic
book YouTuber making a video about that
guy
it is inevitably going to happen but
thing about this is that it switches
over to Johnny Blaze in the early days
of his career which is to say when he
was basically just like a stunt man
going out there and Performing these
crazy Feats and of course as we know or
at least as most people are generally
aware of when it comes to Johnny Blaze
that he goes flying through the whole
stunt things go awry he ends up
basically finding himself in a position
where he's about to die he sells his
soul to the devil and then of course he
ends up becoming the new Ghost Rider the
caveat to all of this is that with this
being the early days of these two
characters their paths ultimately meet
but not right away instead what we
actually end up doing is picking up at
the orphanage where the director
basically tells Dr Ada to just get rid
of bran because the other kids are
terrified of him and having him here is
putting the other kids in a situation of
high duress he knows that it's not like
the best thing to do but the reality is
that he just doesn't really seem to care
all that much and so in the midst of all
this really when there's like the
discussion question of getting rid of
him and the other kids start waking up
and really seem intent on like doing
Bram harm Blood starts dripping onto
Ada's shoulder and when they look up and
they get into the room they end up
finding that Bram has just like twisted
and mutilated all these kids into like
this just monstrosity of a creature and
they don't even know how to interpret
what it is that they're seeing but
that's why things are popping off here
is because this cycle is repeating
itself right Bram is doing this yet
again and so what happens is that where
you have you know Wolverine and Colossus
and storm and all these characters
gather together in the X-Men mansion
again this is taking place in the past
that of course you end up having Bram
who arrives on the scene now again there
is this kind of offhanded remark by
Katie Pride where she asked storm like
why don't you do anything about this
rain and just make it like clear skies
and she's like am I some kind of a
meteorologist and the answer is like yes
storm you control the weather if I were
you everywhere I went would be 75
degrees with a cool breeze right that's
what I would do if I could control the
weather right that just I make it nice
everywhere I went but when Kitty pride
gets outside to check out kind of what's
going on especially with the power going
out that Bram is just kind of standing
there and initially it freaks her out
and in fact when Wolverine goes to the
basement to get candles and comes back
upstairs Colossus is taken out Kitty
pride is taken out right and literally
it's just Bram out there in this demonic
form Now by all standards of measurement
right if you're familiar with New
Mutants by all standards of measurement
this looks like demon bear that's
exactly what it looks like and I would
go so far as to argue it probably is
right but like this is an extremely
powerful demonic Force demon bear is
nothing to be trifled with and in fact
it can overwhelm and overpower Charles
Xavier it's one of the most powerful
forces in existence only like the most
capable telepaths have the ability to
overcome this thing the problem here is
that once you switch back over to Johnny
Blaze and Johnny Blaze is kind of
recovering from his injury after having
become the Ghost Rider he has a sort of
demonic Compass which is to say he sort
of knows where demons are and he seeks
them out and realizing that like there
is an incredibly powerful demonic force
on Earth operating in the Here and Now
specifically at the X-Men mansion he
turns into Ghost Rider and then
immediately goes on the hunt now the
thing about this is because he's Ghost
Rider for the very first time it's the
very first time that he and Wolverine
meet and so where demon bear just takes
off right Bram just like runs off and
that's basically it Wolverine is hot on
this Trail only to run directly into
Ghost Rider and you actually get this
fight between the two of them and it's a
really really really cool moment right
like these two guys duking it out with
each other because a fight between
Wolverine and Ghost Rider is really a
great question of like who would
actually win so I want to know down in
the comments section right if it was
like a knock down drag out No Holds
Barred fight just based strictly on
their feet and what they're capable of
who wins in a fight between Ghost Rider
and Wolverine because technically
Wolverine does get overpowered here
right like the flaming chains and all
that kind of stuff show up you know
Ghost Riders like I have such sights to
show you but it's that kind of a thing
right like he overpowers the guy and so
I want to know who you all think would
actually come out on top in like a fight
to the death between these two guys but
following this you basically pick up
with Ada where she ends up finding Bram
just kind of walking down the road and
Edo ultimately takes him in that where
he talks about how all he wanted was a
family he didn't want to be left alone
and she realizes that the director of
The Orphanage is just going to get rid
of Bram at the first opportunity that he
gets the only person that really seems
to care about him is Ada because she's
emotionally invested and so switch over
to the present day something's popped
off we don't know what it was but things
seemed to go sideways pretty fast
because the house that ADA resided in
after taking Bram in has now all gone to
pot right bram's all grown up he's like
an adult now but the issue is that he
has basically done the exact same thing
he did before which is twisting
everybody's body parts into like this
just monstrosity that resembles
something that you would see in some
Modern Art Museum or something like that
right it's pretty messed up but with
Ghost Rider and with Wolverine brought
together due to this circumstance yet
again the two joined forces to basically
track down and Destroy one of the most
powerful demonic entities that's ever
existed in the history of Marvel comics
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on fall of X make sure you
click the link to this playlist and I
will catch you all later
peace